hey everybody welcome to another
rollback where episodes from the audio
only days of the podcast get a second
life here on YouTube for the very first
time
rollbacks also serve as a way for me to
highlight and resurface the very best of
the early days of the show including
today's conversation with a man widely
considered to be the most accomplished
high altitude climber in the world and
one of the most respected Adventure
athletes of all time Conrad anchor
Conrad is renowned for specializing in
the highest and most technically
challenging mountainous sense in the
world Conquering the trickiest peak
spread across the high Himalayas
Antarctica Alaska and the big walls of
Patagonia he has summited Everest three
times including a successful 2012 Ascent
without the aid of supplemental oxygen a
feat reserved for only the most elite
Mountaineers
the impetus for this conversation which
was recorded way back in August of 2015
was the release of a documentary that
chronicled Conrad's 2011 attempt to
Summit a peak previously thought
impossible the Sharks fan of meru which
was and is considered the most
technically complicated and dangerous
peak in the Himalayas it's truly an
astonishing Tale the film aptly named
meru is visceral it's harrowing and it's
terrifying as much as it is inspiring
really a must-watch if you haven't
checked it out yet and this conversation
covers Conrad's truly extraordinary life
and what he's learned throughout all of
his incredible Adventures Conrad is a
beautiful man somebody I'm proud to call
friend and I'm excited to share this
exchange with all of you so please hit
that subscribe button and enjoy
foreign
it's really great to see you actually uh
this has been a long time in the coming
ever ever ever since we uh met up at
Summit and I got to hear you uh give
your give your talk and we bonded a
little bit I've been wanting to make
this day happen so it took a little
while but I'm really psyched to be
sitting with you oh thank you Rich it's
uh I learned more about you from your
podcast and you know about me yeah I
don't know about that there's there's
plenty there's plenty of information out
there about you and I think
uh The World At Large is uh on the cusp
of learning quite a bit more about you
coming in a couple weeks yeah with the
release of meru well yeah that will be
um thanks to uh Jimmy renan and chai and
for making a great movie it really is a
great movie yeah yeah I would just have
a couple of snapshots and a Campfire
story from it but they've uh they've put
it there for many people to enjoy yeah
and it's um
I would say that it is exceptional on
many levels
um
I think first and foremost because it
has the potential to break through the
typical kind of Adventure movie genre to
touch mainstream audiences you know and
I think that that was it's already been
sort of pre-vetted in that regard by
winning the audience award at Sundance
sort of proving its medal in terms of
having a broad appeal to a wider
audience so I'm interested in kind of
exploring
uh why you think I mean I have some
ideas myself but why you think this
movie perhaps is a little bit different
from the average climbing or Adventure
themed movie
great well yeah well yeah it'll be
interesting to see how it uh if it goes
a bit a bit bigger but um yeah there's
always um
there's climbing movies and then there's
movies about climbers and I think this
one is about climbers and why we go out
there and why we do it and um it's a
real film there's no Recreation
everything that we
shot on meru was there so we didn't go
back and and make something up and then
interwoven into everything is the story
of Jimmy and what led up to that point
and then ran on
um and and then mentorship and
friendship and then my personal story
interwoven it so there's three or four
stories that go into it in addition to
the um
the the story of The meru Climb right
and uh you just mentioned a whole bunch
of inflection points that I want to get
into but I think in terms of the film uh
I mean certainly the the cinematography
and the storytelling is exceptional I
mean I think you know from the very
first whoops spell there uh from the
very first kind of sequence where it
opens up and uh you guys are are perched
on that portal Edge and you can kind of
hear the wind and you can hear very
distinctly like the Rippling in the tent
and then there's that Avalanche I mean
it's so vivid and harrowing it really
transports you like right to that place
and you know you can almost you know I
wouldn't say empathize because I think
only you guys know exactly what that's
like but for an audience member to get
about as close to what that must feel
like as possible on film I mean it's
really you're gripped from the get-go
but then beyond that it's it is it's a
character movie It's Your Story it's the
story of your teammates it's the story
of your families and I think that that
provides an entry point an emotional
connection point for the audience to
kind of go on this journey with you and
relate to it perhaps in a way that
um a more typical kind of climbing movie
or Adventure movie would allow you to
yeah so yeah I'm excited I'm excited
it's how many theaters is it going to be
rolling out in it starts on the 14th of
August and it opens in New York
Minneapolis Denver and Los Angeles and
then the next rollout is a few days
later and it has a broader but each day
the people at music box are they're
adding new theaters to it so yeah it's
um I this I'm pretty new to it I've been
in the outdoor industry for 30 years but
the big movie stuff is kind of right I
really don't know much about it and so
it um I guess someone related to me that
one theater picks it up and it starts
going bigger and then all of a sudden
they all you get a dog pile effect and
so right well hopefully that happens and
people in Kansas and and Arkansas are
gonna
in Tennessee they're going to want to
see something like this so that would be
um that would be the best thing because
obviously within the circles that we
travel and people that are that are into
exercise yeah they're going to see
Health they're they're already tuned
into it right
but to to break out into that larger
audience I think has uh there's a good
potential I think so I think so for sure
were you at Sundance when it screened
when it premiered yeah we were there at
Sundance so it was um it was really
touching to uh to see it that's the
first time I'd seen it on a large screen
and then to be in the back of the
audience and to observe the
um how the how they're reacting to it
and they're sitting on the edge of their
seat and they're you can see them
gripping their arm rest or they're going
like that or some of our little humorous
moments in there that they they chuckle
at them too right and um and at the end
of the day it's real stuff and as you
pointed out the opening scene when we're
there on the side of the mountain it um
we were living that we were up on the
side of that meru for 12 days when we
had a 2011 journey and so it was like
that was the that look on the face is
the that's what happened up there
better you than me and I'm not a good
actor because I'm always like
well I mean everyone looks really pretty
calm but there's a palpable kind of
um not foreboding because that's too
negative but like sort of a undercurrent
of tension and nervous expectation about
what is going what is to come yeah when
you're up there on a big wall of that
size and so imagine this thing is
probably seven thousand feet of
gravity and so you're in this ocean of
gravity and you drop your sunglasses
they're going to go tumbling down and if
you don't have a backup you're going to
go snow blind because you're in the
Himalayas and the sun's out if you drop
your ropes you don't have a way to get
down so there's this sense of immediacy
and urgency that um
that you have to as you and your team
that have to everything you've prepared
for is on the line at that moment at
that time and I don't find that and
I mean day-to-day life we're just so
we're over subscribed over stimulated
there's just too much stuff going on and
you're driving around and this and that
nothing's really that immediate or
important
and
when you're on a climb like that it's
like well you have a goal of making it
to the summit but if you screw up
gravity
doesn't
play favorites it's going to let you
know right away that you made a mistake
right uh certainly anchoring you in the
moment in a way that uh is probably you
know escapes you in your daily life of
course right which is why I like it is
I'm um
I'm a hyperactive high-strung you know I
was a bouncing off the wall kid right
right right right well let's let's take
it back and uh and and set the stage a
little bit on you know kind of how you
got into all of this I mean I know that
you
you grew up your dad was in the service
and your mother was is German right yeah
and and they met when he was overseas
but you kind of grew up in a household
where backpacking trips were that was
the summer vacation right so you were
introduced to this culture
uh at a fairly young age yep that's
correct and my father said the family is
from Tuolumne County here in California
and my mother sister and brother still
live there and so we would get up into
the High Sierra and we'd go out with
mules and fly fishing and and and
that was what we did we kind of lived
you know went up there and ate pancakes
and I would make little mud dams and
Float Twigs down the creek and we did
that every summer for two weeks and so
that was my introduction to it and then
started out Peak bagging and then into
roped climbing in my teen years was that
something that you did with your dad or
you just started you started to kind of
take it next level as you matured he
gave me an introduction to it so it was
we went repelling with Gold Line and
around your waist and and the dolpher
sits and I remember getting a rope burn
and you know all those things and then
it was like okay I'm gonna find I'm
gonna do more of that so was it
something that
during those early backpack trips you
locked in on and knew kind of from the
get-go like oh I have a passion for this
that maybe surpasses the other people
that I'm doing this with I mean did or
did it happen gradually like your
passion and your love for
adventure sports yeah there's
um there's this one moment when we'd
been out for two weeks and we would go
up in the High Country and we'd come
back through the High Sierra camps and
so there are these pack animal stocked
camps up in the High Country and we were
coming back in and there was this moment
after being out for two weeks and hiking
down the trail that it was like wow this
is the happiest I am and I was 14 and it
was just sort of
it wasn't like I needed to be
competitive with someone else because it
was um it wasn't like oh I'm going to be
a better climber than them and um and
part of the reason I really got into
that is because I was turned off by
competitive Sports and the pressure and
the and just sort of the
the
way that
children are forced to antagonize other
kids and and to be competitive and to be
better and so I was like wow I'm not
into that but I'm into sports I'm into
physical activity and so that moment
hiking out of the mountains it was like
wow this is it this is my happy place
and so
I was like whatever work I need to do so
um what this is the carpentry out yeah
I'm gonna work to live a good quality of
life and that was I've always stayed
true to that yeah and it is a very
unique sport in that regard it isn't
competitive uh there's certainly
teamwork plays into you know plays in in
a gigantic way but it's about your
relationship with yourself and your
environment yeah and that's for me is
the most significant part of it it was
that if you and I go out climbing or we
do a long
a 30-mile run in the middle of nowhere
we're a team we have to make sure that
we're working together and that we're
not going to make a mistake and that and
the adversary is the elements it's the
amount it's gravity it's the storm it's
the bad rock or something like that so
rather than say if we're playing tennis
where we go back and forth and then the
goal is to sort of become a um is to is
to beat them and then you hop over the
net and you shake your hand and this
this like false modesty and you're like
yeah but I crushed him and so you're
like it's um and I was always
um it just was
um it was a
it was it just wasn't the right way to
interact with humans and I think that I
mean part of it playing football as a
kid in middle school I signed up and I
played it and it was just this
um
I like sports I had a lot of energy sort
of fit of energy I had to put it
somewhere but then I realized that it
was just so intense and then you're the
the verb of hitting someone I mean
that's what they call it when you tackle
them right you come away from it and
it's it's sort of like wow it's not a
very healthy way to to have humans
interact with other humans and so I
really latched on to scouting and I had
a great scout master and Jesus
guy that was a Korean War of that and he
was convinced all the youth of today
especially the young men were turning to
a bunch of candy asses and it was his
job to go out and I'm still character so
he would do the winter camping trips and
all these these great things uh well
he's right about that yeah by the way
yeah and I still
yeah I want to pass that on to the next
Generation too because you go out and
and you try something more challenging
and you come away with a
um
a sense of
that what you can do and what and your
ability but you're also humbled by it I
think that that um
that being humble to other
to yourself and to other people it's a
really healthy foundation and I think
probably in the next sort of big meta
evolution of of human mind of where
we're going to be is that we're coming
into a more kind and more
reciprocal a more loving Society rather
something that's antagonistic I hope so
but that being said
I watched the Super Bowl every year and
it's not really crazy yeah if you're
like watching this well we live in the
world you know you're not living in a
cave like those amazing sados that you
pass on the path on your way up to meru
oh man how beautiful are those guys
unbelievable right yeah in the film
where you're we're walking through there
and they're just their look in their
eyes and the way that they bow and they
touch their heart to you and just
meeting them I mean that is the every
time those those um all three
Expeditions I went to meru to go visit
it was uh interacting with the sadhus
and going and visiting with them asking
them for their blessing before we go and
climb on the mountain and they're like
yeah tell us what's up there yeah it's a
really special place they weren't like
oh you can't go there it's a bad thing
it's like wow you there's something
that's driven you are you're a pilgrim
and you are a seeker and so they
respected that interesting yeah and I
mean they're holding a lot of energy
those guys you know they're carrying a
certain vibration up there I think I
mean can you feel that when you interact
with those guys yeah they're the the
sarus namatagis the the women that are
of the Holy life they're they've
renounced material things and they're
um they live off the benevolence of
other people and so here we are trekking
up going up to 14 000 feet
um tabovan which is the meadow at this
basis shivling so we have all these
sadhus that worship Shiva which is a
deity and the Hindu religion and so they
they lived there at 14 000 feet and
you'll have these
um these these really
wise
men and an occasional woman that are up
there and they're living under a rock
with some tarps and and the cotton sorry
type rap clothing and we're up there
with inflated like all right now we're
the candidates yeah yeah well they're
not quite taking it up to the notch that
you are but it is interesting what was
that ceremony that that you attended
that's in the film yeah the start that
ceremony is at the in gangotri which is
the jumping off point so it's the end of
the road and it's the town of gangotri
and Upstream is the source of the Ganges
River so again Jesus is the most sacred
River for the Hindu religion and this
Valley where shivling and bhagarathi and
meru is steeped in the Hindu mythology
yeah I mean that's that's like the
vortex yeah so they're going in there
and it's like
wow and Lord Shiva hung out on top of
shivling
for 40 000 years and then it brought
the ganga River down with his hair and
then his wife is the the peak across the
way and then meru is the center of the
universe and if we think about this that
when
Hindu religion came into being is
probably
um three to five thousand years it's a
it's a very old religion that when the
pilgrims came up and they hiked up into
this Valley and saw these immense Peaks
that probably had more ice on them than
they do now forting the river was just
an incredible thing there was no Bridges
not even rope Bridges and we did have to
go on one side of the mountain it was a
real
challenge to get there and they finally
got up and they looked at these Peaks
and they were just going all the way up
to the sky and I mean now we're before
we're even born we know that Jets exist
in airplanes and you can have a building
this
tall as the Empire State Building all
these things so but without knowing that
if you were you lived out in the plains
of India and a Seeker came and told you
that there was a mountain that went to
the to the top of the world and that was
it so that meru and then seeing that
Peak and then having that come out and
being a
spreading all the way as far as Myanmar
where they have in Indochina where the
there is a temple of meru there that's
um
part of Angora watt so it's just kind of
how that that reach of it and everything
like that so it's a pretty
um to there's many mountains in in the
world but they're this having that
that sense of uh connection to the
culture was pretty special yeah that's
cool it has a whole you know history in
that culture that I was not aware of
that's amazing
very cool so taking it back to you as
this I mean you've you were you've sort
of self-described yourself as a
hyperactive kid right I mean do you
think that if you were growing up now
like you probably would have been
medicated right like let's calm this guy
down let's you know get him to fit in
the Box as opposed to you know you were
lucky enough fortunate enough to have
you know a loving family that
said well we got this kid like we got to
figure out a way to get him to channel
this energy that he has in a productive
way yeah right and we're supported in
that yeah and I think it in the 60s they
were medicating children in in at my age
and that was my mother
um in particularly my mother and my
father too but my mother was she was the
one that put her foot down she said no
and she's still at this date doesn't
like to go to the hospital or doctors or
medications or anything like that and
I'm that way too I'm averse to it I'd
rather I just don't
I don't have a need for it and so they
she said no and she simply attributed to
okay he's got too much sugar and there's
not enough physical actually yeah so it
was like let's just burn them out every
day more exercising less sugar that was
her remedy for it and I think it was um
it really made sense and to see that and
it'd be great to when we have children
now especially um young boys and when I
visit
um
classrooms and stuff
now there's a weird buzzing noise hold
on let me just pause it for a second
starting up again sorry about that we
had a weird buzzing noise had a little
time out so where were we we were
talking about medicating children and
this um this sort of level
of where we're at and so I enjoy uh
talking to Children about science fourth
and fifth graders giving them going to
classrooms and I see these these
children a lot of them young boys that
are just bouncing up the wall they're
hyperactive and there's all this energy
in them and rather than trying to
say okay we're going to solve this with
ritalin or something like that or some
sort of medication what can we do to
encourage these and work it to their
benefit and I think that's I was just as
a kid I was hyperactive High Strung I
can look back at my report cards from
second and third grade he couldn't sit
still it couldn't hold his attention for
a couple of minutes he's probably a kid
but we just don't know what to do with
them right oh my God
so and I think to this where I am now I
am a very hyper situationally aware
person I mean both you and I are we
heard the buzz in this microphone right
away right okay too distracting like I
had to stop yeah and so if I'm driving
down the road I'm I'm like okay this is
the this is la is four four lanes wide
of traffic and everyone's going 70 and
there's a a scrap hauler up there it's
just load secure if there was to be a
piece of metal that came off what would
I do if I'm climbing if I don't protect
the second put a piece of gear in there
there could be a potential mistake so
I'm thinking about a worst case scenario
and then planning about it in reverse
and so if you have that hyper
situational awareness you you make for
to be a good pilot a good climber you
want someone that really takes in all
that all that data point and in a
classroom as a young kid it was absolute
craziness because I tried to attend to
them all and I still when I sit down to
my computer if I don't have a list of
the emails I need to do and how I'm
going to structure my time I just
totally yeah I would imagine that I'm
going everywhere if you were yeah if you
lived in New York City you just you'd be
in a concentrative freak out right like
because there's too much stimuli right
but when you're when you're on the
mountain
um you can Channel all of that hyper
vigilance onto the one task at hand
because there's really just one thing
you got to do at a time you're aware of
all the variables but it's like what's
the next thing like you're just not a
mission and you're doing one thing yeah
and that's what brings it into me so
climbing gyms provide that and I can I'm
that play with gravity where you're
where you're there and you step off the
ground and you're pulling on the holds
and when you're Outdoors rock climbing
that sad thing and so the Expeditions
are sort of the culmination of all those
experiences number one grand Journey
when you think of
uh you look back on your career as a as
a climber you know I would imagine that
this you know hypersensitivity you would
reflect on that as being part of your
success equation right but like what do
you think it is about you specifically
that distinguishes you from your peers
or that's allowed you to kind of be in
this you know pardon the pun like
rarefied air in terms of the world of
climbers
I and I enjoy it every day I guess I
mean so there's always that sense of but
they all enjoy it yeah
but I'm gonna I'm gonna make you step
out of your sense of modesty here for a
minute so
um I've got good distal circulation so
my hands stay warm in crowded places so
they're sort of um and then having done
enough trips to the altitude I've
um my lungs do well and maybe I've
self-selected to to climate altitude
that's another thing on that but um I
that sense of um
just being
on the edge and being in a really remote
place is incredible and I remember as a
kid I would set up
like pillow forts and I would pretend I
was in a in a tent in Antarctica and it
would be like really there was nothing
else out there and that was like you
would just be like make wind sounds and
it would just it was you know I'd I'd
transport myself out of there and those
kid imaginations are always so rich and
Vivid right and so so it's almost like
you came out of the womb like this
almost like you're channeling some past
life experience you know like this was
this was bred into your imagination from
as far back as you can remember yeah and
I think for certain individuals they're
hardwired in their DNA to go explore and
to have to have a higher risk
acceptance level and those have always
been the Explorers you go back in the
course of history and and the great
books Homer's Odysseys about that where
a few people would go out and leave the
comfort of the tribe or the clan and
then seek something and with a reward if
they come back safely and successfully
but then also the risk of failure and
and not coming back being part of it and
some people that's still there and it's
still part of who they are I mean why do
some people end up being astronauts
because they're the confines of nine to
five are not there and they would rather
do that than
have some other
path in life that wouldn't be as is risk
and with as much exploration right I
mean I think it brings up a really
interesting kind of point about our
culture I mean we're you know our whole
society is sort of founded upon this
idea of you know security and having the
good life and trying to create you know
extra ease in our day-to-day existence
uh you know at the same time we Herald
the heroes we Herald the Risk Takers you
know we love to enjoy those stories but
the message that we're getting is really
not so much to pursue that it's like oh
you know the life of moderation is best
and you know you'd be best served by
having this big screen TV or getting a
nicer car or a nicer house and so I'm
always thinking about like how to
reconcile those two worlds you know what
I mean like like uh you know a big part
of your message is to go outside and
explore right and at the same time you
know we're telling school children you
know we're putting doing helmets on them
the minute they walk outside the house
because we're a fear-based culture
so you know how does that play into
how you communicate you know to the
world and to young people because I know
you talk to young people quite a bit
yeah
um people
we are so conditioned and the media is a
big part of it they want us to buy
a bigger house a more comfortable car
more food more and then they want us to
be list
take on less risk they want us to be
consuming member society which means
you're productive and you have a job and
you can afford more things and status is
accorded with fancier cars and all this
and any sort of these material
measures of life that are there and and
and we relate it to the children we have
it at a very young age and on my part
that there's people that
they're like send me letters and they're
like you're irresponsible you can't be a
parent Alex already tied climbing and
come on you're doing this to the kids
again and you're just incredibly selfish
it's the wrong thing to do and get a
life grow up all these things and so I'm
one I don't like to pass judgment on
other people and I accept everyone as
good and and I won't and say okay that's
fine that's that's your point of view
but we we have this we have to
constantly be
growth in our society is like we need to
we need four percent annually we need to
catch up with China they're growing
faster than we are we're doing and so
this growth versus quality is is a thing
so it's that quantity versus quality of
life type thing and so rather than every
time I go shopping for something that
isn't essential I.E it's not food I I
hold it and I go do I really need this
whatever it might be and am I just
getting it because it's newer one and
that there's a there's like the shopping
crave that that urge that that reward or
and I deserve it I've earned it I mean
life is hard I should treat myself to
these really nice headphones right I'm
always like yeah and so there's like
that there's that um and then a push and
pull yeah and yet I go over to the time
I spent in Nepal and the Nepali people
are some of the the happiest people that
would go under these Villages and
they're like they they're really happy
people and they want to
um they're I mean and yes there are many
people that are happy United States but
oftentimes
there's people that in that you interact
in a public space and they're just
they're not they're some something's
wearing at them and they just I mean
they're
they're walking around with this weight
of unhappiness and sometimes I want to
say hello guess what life is really
short you can't go through thinking like
this yeah yeah yeah and so you see these
people these sados in India the monks
and and Tibet and and so they're living
in the moment and they're
they realize life success in life isn't
equated to material acquisition
what else about that culture do you
think informs their happiness quotient
in Nepal they're very resourceful people
I mean yeah certainly there's
unhappiness there's tragedy and there's
things that happen but um they're
certainly recently yeah and they um
but yeah they uh
they send they tend to be
um
there's like they're it's simple yeah
and I'm struggling for words because I
really don't know what it is and I guess
I'm still trying to answer that and when
I go over there and and so yeah a lot of
them do want to have
um a new pair of jeans and a better cell
phone and things like that and it's easy
for us having all these
these things that make life comfortable
and life easy to say oh isn't it
wouldn't be great to just go sit on the
side of the mountain in a cave but
they're I think part of it is that
there's
um
there's in Nepal it's pedestrian Society
so people are walking and when you walk
on the trail you interact with everyone
you you see them in their eye or if it's
a friend or something like that you say
hello and when you're walking with a
friend from Nepal and they you see how
they interact with their people it's way
different than we're driving in a in a
car in a bus or something like that
where it's you don't have that that sort
of connection families are very
connected and very tight with it so
maybe that has a an underlying part of
it and um that uh there's this
for most of Nepal is is pretty rural I
mean Kathmandu is is a teaming
Metropolis to an overcrowded polluted
Southeast Asian City in like Jakarta and
Bangkok and I mean it's the world is
full of those places but the people when
you get out into the sticks they're um
I mean there's roosters and there's a
simple life and so there's a
there's some happiness there yeah well I
think it's um it's sort of like uh the
blue zones have you you've heard of the
blue zones yeah so Dan yeah I've had Dan
on the podcast and
um you know a big part of it you know
from his exploration into this question
is is that communal aspect of having an
extended family close and and being
close with your neighbors and you know
and the walking and all of that I think
informs all of that so much to be
learned right yeah it's nice to see that
and it's nice to see Dan in his work
looking at data driven not just or yeah
it's not just about traditional right
yeah yeah because you're always
observational and then you end up
extrapolating your own views so if it
works for me then it's got to work for
someone else right and so having that
that those those data points is really
an important thing is now as we have
more data we can then work through those
things and and find out these cultures
in in Japan and and other places that
that have a long life and what are they
what's part of that right so all right
so you're locking into climbing as a
young person when does it become like
when are you taking the leap into you
know all right this is this is what I'm
doing this is my profession and I know
that like you know the the line end up
becoming a professional climber you know
isn't exactly like you know LeBron James
entering the NBA but you know at some
point this becomes basically all that
you're doing and you know what was the
first big Expedition for you in I was 23
and I received a grant from the American
Alpine club to go to Alaska and so
yeah there was four of us and we got
four hundred dollars a hundred dollars
each
already down yeah
1987 we were living big and so we um
we got we drove a blue a spray painted
blue Ford Econo line from Salt Lake up
to Alaska and I love it climbed in the
Alaska range and had this great time and
so that was um I think that was it was a
grant from the American Alpine Club so
it was sort of a something going on with
that but it wasn't
um I continued to climb full time so I
would work after I graduated from the
University of Utah I would work
carpentry and it was I enjoyed that work
and then it was
or at the end of the day I would
my job was done and then I would work
really hard for four or five months and
I would go on a on a trip so
um carpentry High scaling work where
you're working on rope access Cliffs and
buildings and things like that and then
working hard and then going climbing and
that was how I got my start and then um
starting in 92 working with the North
Face right so they're and we've been
with them ever since I mean that's been
an amazing relationship yeah it's been
wonderful and um yeah I started with
them in 83 my retail work so selling and
there was a holly bar gear shop and
there were the Old Roy Holly bars to sew
your own down jacket
they sold carabiners and so that was my
college job I enjoyed that and um so and
then 92 working and helping with Sports
Marketing to
create the story The Brand uses now
right and what is your what's your role
with them today I mean I know you're
you're sort of the athlete team captain
right is that correct yeah how does that
work I mean I know they have uh like
these Summits where all the North Face
athletes get together and from all
disciplines all different kinds of
sports
um and you gotta share stories and all
that kind of stuff like I'm super
jealous like I want to know what that's
like and kind of you know peek into the
world of the North Face athlete team oh
yeah well um I yeah on paper it's
athlete team captain but probably maybe
uh brand Compass over the years so
working with our marketing team and our
strategic Partnerships Corporate social
responsibility
um
film projects things like that and
having this sort of what is legitimate
climbing what's not climbing what's good
what's not and then with our athlete
team we have three areas action
performance and outdoor and so action is
snowboarding skiing free skiing things
like that performances predominantly
trail running and outdoor is climbing
and ski mountaineering and so probably
globally
um about 40 athletes that we have and so
recruitment and development of the
athlete team which is I really enjoy
doing and meeting the prospective
athletes and
with what we do is um
if you
see in Bolt you run the 100 meters you
win it's a quantitative when we get that
but what we're doing is experiential and
when you go out in the mountains whether
you're in shackleton's time or Lewis and
Clark's time you experience it and you
come back and you share it you would
write about it in those guys and then
Shackleton a had still cameras that came
along and using these as examples and so
that experiential part of it is key to
what we do so in finding athletes that
are good at what they do and that have
an ability to share their story with
people that are
that are nice affable people they're
charismatic they're intelligent and all
these sort of these great things that
that we do so and it's been um
a great part of of doing that and then
fostering sort of a team and then
cross-pollinating between the various
disciplines and being able to work with
our um
the the product development team and the
sales team to get what we hope the
athletes can then do for the brand and
then
sharing them and helping them to go with
that right so it's nothing I mean all
the big Brands youth athletes to to
whether you're selling golf clubs or
baseballs or anything like that and
we're selling outdoor gear and so
there's um
it's been a great journey I really enjoy
the brand they've trusted with me what
we're doing and then also now as we're
um
trying to get more people outdoors and
more people healthier and they're like
these ideas that we're going to touch on
here in a little bit they're like here's
the runway go with that and find out the
people that you can work with and what
are we going to do to to get this to get
this going because
they're like yeah sure we want to sell
more raincoats sleeping bags and Tents
but at the end of the day if we get if
we the the BMI of America is less and
we're healthier and all these key
metrics are lower than we've done a good
thing and that's you can look at it from
any prism you can look at it from the
prism of I'm an American it's the
Patriotic thing to do or you can look at
the prism that I tend to look at things
it's the right thing it's this next
um
growth in terms of kindness and
understanding of humans and and that
this fundamental experience of being
outdoors is at the foundation of that
right yeah well it's it's you've you've
done a great job and the Brand's done a
great job because the the content that
gets put out is always of a super high
quality and the storytelling is always
extraordinary and it's not really you
know they're not ads you know it's like
yeah you'll see like oh this is the
North Face you know presents or
something like that but then it's really
just about whatever Adventure is being
told in that in that film so they're
always really cool the one team over
there that does that yeah I know I know
I know but it's cool and I've had a
couple of the the runner guys I had
Timothy Olson on the podcast and I've
had Dean Hernandez on too and those guys
are both you know they're in a I mean
Dean's different because he's more more
it's more like a lifestyle with his
running now you know Timothy's still
competing but he's such a charismatic
beautiful guy and he has such a an Adept
way of like sharing sharing his
experience of the world so I think it's
a good fit with you guys which is cool
so all right so when did the big you
know like you've climbed Everest three
times you know the big sort of things
that have put you on the map when does
that start to begin
probably in the mid 90s so
um there's um probably most climbers
have sort of a two decade window of
their
when they're at their their bank and
their Prime and so starting in the 90s
was that was
um trips and 96 did an expedition to um
Antarctica with National Geographic and
who's with Alex Lowe and um
Rick Ridgeway and Gordon wiltse Mike
Graber and John krakauer and we climbed
a
this Granite Tower in the middle of the
ice cap and so that was a a fun
Expedition and sort of a break going a
little bit bigger and then on the first
of May 1999 on an expedition to the
north side of Everest I
came across the frozen well-preserved
body of George Mallory and then so that
was for better or worse I mean it went
around the world it was just in the
nascent age of the internet and internet
reporting and sort of the
mountain Zone was the the conduit that
all that information went out from so it
was um some people thought it was a
great thing other people it was uh I was
I was vilified and understandably wow
yeah I mean from what I understand I
mean for better or worse that kind of
put you in the on the map in certain
ways and overshadowed some of the other
things that you've done I mean it is an
amazing thing to discover his body
um it was more in the I mean you didn't
really have anything to do with how the
photographs got disseminated right they
just sort of leaked out and then that
sort of cast a shadow on how the story
was being told is that fair there's um
yeah the photos went through a uh so the
family got upset yeah through an agency
and then the agency
um
um went to the highest bidder and it was
the Tabloid press so that was um
something is
as important as this there was um and
significant it would have been
um and that's that's it's many years
back and neither here right so but just
explain who George Mallory was I mean he
attempted this avarice climb in 1924 a
very different age in climbing yeah
George Mallory was the
the one English clamor that was part of
all three of the early Everest
Expeditions so he was there 21 22 and 24
and 21 they figured out how to get to
the North Pole via the Northeast Fork of
the wrong book Glacier I mean this is an
area that was unmapped it was blank they
had to walk all the way in over from
Darjeeling up over the Tulip law through
shigaze I mean just an Incredible
Journey on foot with with Paddock
animals to get to the base came back in
1922 they were a little late in getting
there
and a
Monsoon Avalanche came in and swept away
seven of the Sherpas that were climbing
with them and they the Expedition turned
back in the face of that that loss they
took 23 off
um because it was they needed more time
to organize and to get prepared and then
they came back in 24 early enough
to beat the monsoon which usually sets
in around the first of June and lasts
until the first of September and that's
when the majority of the moisture comes
onto the Himalayas especially in
altitude and they gave it a go and it
was on the 8th of June that um
they disappeared into the clouds around
noon local time last seen by Noel O'Dell
a geologist today behind them in support
and he had commented that they were
moving expeditiously as if to make up
for lost time
subsequently the question always became
could they have made it to the top 29
years before Sir Edmund Hillary and
tensing Norgay did in 1953.
no one ever knew no one we it's
generally accepted they didn't make it
to the top that they lost their lives
somewhere
um in between the first step and the
yellow band or maybe moving up towards
the Second Step but not above the Second
Step these are Cliff features on the
North East Ridge of Mount Everest so um
but he was um a great character he had
served in the
um the first world war in the Battle of
yah pris and so he'd seen the loss of
life in combat and and sort of that that
harsh end of things but he was also
passionate about climbing and the Arts
and letters he was a school teacher and
his wife had
giving them
a blessing to go on this Expedition and
he disappeared and on June 8th Left
Behind three children
Claire was still alive in 1999 when
we made the discovery and his son John
is still alive living in South Africa
and his grandson George is in Australia
so there's and in connection with her
part of the intention of your Expedition
was to retrace these steps and and
perhaps solve this mystery right yeah
could they have overcome this the Second
Step this Cliff band up at uh 28 300
feet right and as you're you're making
your way up you kind of diverged off the
path that you were headed on right and
then something caught your eye yeah we
had set out to look for George Mallory's
body that was we were very clear about
that it was the Mallory and Irvine
research Expedition it was uh funded by
PBS and
BBC zdaf in Germany and HK so most of
the those four countries their national
uh but their public television
exhibition organized and led by Eric
Simonson so our goal was specifically to
look for the body of George Mallory I
wasn't
specifically a Searcher I was more on
the um to go have a go at the second
step to have to see how difficult that
Cliff band was and um that was uh so we
went on to a traversing contouring
around at uh
8 300 meters I hadn't been to that
elevation before and and
looking on the features of the mountain
where um
where when people fall on big mountains
not a cliff where you kind of it's like
a Wily coyote Anvil coming off the edge
of a the bottom and then
the rotary gets up and runs away but um
this you tumble down you tumble yeah and
you end up in certain places and Eddies
just like you do when the rivers whereas
a stick might come in behind a rock
something like that and so there were
certain places on the mountain that I
realized that there was a good chance
there would a body would be there and
then it was a very dry year in 1999 and
um a very humbling moment to come across
his body 75 years after he had passed
away and
and so what did what did how did you
deal with that Discovery I mean did
everybody come together and we we came
together and we um we you know from a
very
quasi-scientific point we performed high
altitude archeology I wish I had more
archaeological training going into it I
would have treated the site vastly
different in terms of measuring it in
quadrants and
um I mean that was a but you're also at
24
000 yeah
yeah out of air up there but um yeah we
um brought back some of his personal
effects and they were returned to the
family
and performed a committal service read
the 103rd Psalm and did what we could to
bury his body there at that moment um
and sort of bring Circle to his life
right and based on your observation and
your rudimentary archaeological skills I
mean were you able to
make a reasonable conclusion about
whether he had summoned it or not
the best of
um
I
yeah the best of my my understanding on
it would be this would be their Summit
day they left June 8th they were a
little late leaving camp they didn't
leave nowadays climbers leave it as it
really is 9 pm the night before or we
left at that time about one in the
morning and climbed through the night
but when Odell got to their Camp their
flashlights were still in the tent so
they'd left the tent without taking
their flashlights and these were
flashlights that were they weren't
headlamps they weren't these fancy
things and batteries were I mean they'd
hold these batteries
on a ship through the Suez Canal all the
way around I mean just gone for the long
time not to mention all the champagne
too right Champaign
so they finally get all this stuff there
and they left their their flashlights in
the tent they headed out and they
climbed up through the um
the yellow band which is pretty tricky
to rain it's the steepest section on the
North to Northeast Ridge at that point
the route that Mallory had pioneered and
they got above that and they traversed
over probably to the base of the first
step and it was in that vicinity that
Odell had last seen them as the clouds
built up in the afternoon which is
typical pre-monsoon accumulation of
clouds condensation they build and then
they dissipate in the evening as the
clouds as the temperature drops
and they had turned around were coming
back down and one or the two of them had
slipped descending the yellow band which
is
it's not outward facing you're just
marching downhill you have to turn
inside and climb and they weren't using
protection as we now use it which is to
put in a either a piton which is the
first type of protection or a stopper or
a spring-loaded camming device all three
of those things you can then put them in
the cliff and then you can attach a
carabiner and you clip your rope through
there and this is the technique that
climbers use that came from sailing so
the original the belay the Bollard
carabiners all these things came from
sailing so there was someone that
cross-pollinated between sailing and
climbing and using those techniques but
they were not using those techniques in
1924 so they were probably down soloing
so each person they have a rope between
them and the Rope has about as much
security as say as when you're in the
subway and it's rocking along and you
grab the the the the the heavy handle
yeah and it'll keep you from toppling
over but you're not putting 100 of your
weight on there so if someone would slip
you could grab that rope real quick and
keep them from tumbling down but it's
not in the sense that that say on the
meru film where you see that I mean it's
very elaborate we're using ropes and for
Upward progress and then we repel down
on them and how we use the modern
climate protection and equalizing them
and it's very much a different sport
than it was in 1924 so one of them
slipped pulled the other one off and the
Rope
snapped Mallory fell down and had a
compound fracture of his right leg and
my guess is that he was still cognizant
at those last moments of his life
because his body is is resting uphill
most of the time when you're unconscious
because we're top heavy we end up with
our heads downhill and so when you uh
see someone that's had a bad fall they
end up bought head downhill and that
right so this case his head was uphill
and it seemed like he'd crossed his
like I mean he could have been moved by
another climber in subsequent years but
um
he probably for a moment or two he
thought that he could uh that rescue
someone would come help him out but um
life left him and then he there he was
there he was yeah well in your
occupation uh I would imagine coming
upon
a dead body is part of what happens we
especially on a mountain like Everest
and there's um you get up above 26 000
feet 8 000 meters and you're on borrowed
time I mean the human body
we have not evolved to
survive there we use tools to to get
through their insulative tools crampons
and supplemental oxygen on along those
lines but if you are a climber you have
to make peace with death you have to
understand that um
that it um that you could die and then
when you see a body in the mountains it
um it's a little bit shocking initially
when you see that body but then you
um you accept it and I guess in that
sense I
I
think that we've sort of Taken mortality
and morbidity and we've made it into a
carnival type thing you look at all the
movies now and you'll be people get
killed 20 times in the movie and we're
just sort of
it's like well it just happens they got
shot five times you turn on the TV and
there's like boom boom boom and if you
think back 200 years there wasn't that
there might be a
spy novel where oh he shot them right
well it's a weird thing because yeah on
television or in movies it's you're
constantly bombarded with images of
death but in our daily lives we walk
around really not giving it its proper
due and we all sort of think that we're
somehow going to be the exception of the
ruler yeah you know we defer thinking
about it and try to deny its
inevitability in our life but with what
you do it's it's ever present right
unless it's in the Forefront of your
Consciousness I would imagine in a way
that it isn't for most people and it's a
I think it's a good thing you know I
mean it you look at how we treat our
elderly rather than trying to embrace
them and and you know maybe it's one of
these things and and Dan's book about
how you live with your elderly and
you're there with them rather than
saying okay they're a burden to us let's
move them to the rest home and then they
go into the hospital and when they
finally expire there's not that maybe
there might be surrounded by friends and
family or something like that but it's
um we're just not
um there in that yeah in that full and
our whole industry is
about you have to be
younger healthier fitter happier go to
the plastic surgeon go do this and it's
I think accepting where you are in your
stage of life and that the foundation of
that is today is the best day of your
life and tomorrow is going to be the
next best day of your life and that yeah
I'm I'm not as strong as I was in my 30s
and when I was in my 30s I wasn't as
strong as Alex and old as a Grammer so I
am not trying to catch up and be
competitive with them but to celebrate
that next Generation being
better artists being better scientists
being better athletes and that we're all
on this spinning globe for just a very
short period of time yeah yeah yeah and
and that gets into mentorship and the
importance of mentorship and I want to
get into that in a minute but while
we're kind of stuck on Everest here for
a minute uh you know you've summoned it
Everest three times and you know I think
to the average you know person
um you know Everest is the ultimate you
know it's the highest peak
um but that doesn't necessarily mean
that it's the most difficult Ascent as
you as becomes evident when you watch a
film like meru but with respect to
Everest specifically you know over the
last I don't know 10 or 20 years you
would know better than me it's almost
become
like this bucket list item for you know
the investment banker of the day to say
I'm going to do this right so you have
this you know influx of more people than
ever descending on this mountain perhaps
you know most of which or many of which
are not are ill-equipped or ill-prepared
to do it
um you know how what is your perspective
on that you know in terms of the amount
of people that are treading up you know
this to this hollowed Peak so to speak
Everest will continue to
attract people to go climate there is
only one point and it's if only 3 000
people have climbed it out of seven and
a half billion people it's still a
sought after goal and um
the
the people of Nepal the sherpa they have
created an industry around getting
people to the top and they are hard
workers they the root has fixed rope
from the bottom all the way to the top
so
um
it's not a conveyor belt but it's a
safety line that goes all the way to the
top and it's not this is permanently
there each season it gets re-equipped
and so there's a tremendous amount of
work that the Nepali in particularly the
sherpa people are doing on behalf of
these Expeditions that go up there and
the standard route on the south side and
the north side both those routes are
they're unique sort of Everest type
climbing they're not Adventure climbing
it's not first Ascent climbing it's not
a different type of climbing and to to
compare them to those other types of
climbing sort of like the climbing on
meru or the climbing on Yosemite is
you're looking at apples to oranges and
so yes it is there's a lot of people
going up Mount Everest it is a sought
after Peak but
in
at the end of the day I'd rather see the
investment banker
going to climb a mountain because rather
than hunting a a rare animal and I mean
we don't have enough animals left on
this planet especially those charismatic
megafauna that look good above your your
mantel price
so I mean that's in the news the last
day or two and so it's um it's not just
investment bankers it's dentists yeah
everyone you could be a mechanic yeah
and so there's um it's a real
um climbing a big mountain so it's it's
a good thing especially something like
Everest it's a it employs a lot of
people in in Nepal
um and Nepal and Tibet and
um as they are they manage and regulate
the mountain until they have done a
an overview of
the carrying capacity and how that
mountain can then be managed is going to
be a bit of a
it's a goat farm over there right so but
this year is the first year since
1974 or something like that that Everest
will not have a summit on it so it's
gonna
sort of recuperate and oh really so I
didn't know that so what is that about
yeah the um with the Avalanche that uh
struck base camp as a result of the
earthquake on the 25th of April 2015.
there um it's this lockdown yeah they
closed up the season and I I don't think
there are any um post Monsoon
Expeditions going over there they'd be
setting up right now and there'd be
right it'd be in the news but I haven't
heard of anyone so yeah giving them out
an arrest and um yeah there is some talk
in the mountaineering communities to
to have another rest here to say okay
we're no
no climbing on Everest everyone go climb
other Peaks and so well the amount of
debris that must be accumulating up
there has got to be vast right and
extensive I mean when you're going up
you must see stuff all over the place
they're doing a good job are they yeah
they're starting in the 90s they had
Everest cleanup Expeditions and now when
you go there you have to post a a bond
per person of about a thousand dollars
or so that you bring your your rubbish
down so there's um they're
um they're doing a good job with that
they're getting it out of there things
like oxygen cylinders or souvenirs so
there there's a value to them so you
have a Market Force encouraging people
to bring them down and then and the ones
that can be reused or recycled but um
yeah there's some how we handle that
many people
um and the challenges of human waste and
and fresh water on a small village of a
thousand people that are trying to climb
one route are pretty outstanding and so
until Nepal and Sycamore National Park
comes up with a management plan similar
to what uh Denali National Park has for
climbing Denali the highest point in
Alaska and North America there's it'll
be a little bit of a challenge of how
they accommodate
that many people interesting
so back to this issue of death and the
ever-present kind of awareness of its uh
you know of its possibility with what
you do I mean in your own personal Story
You've you know you've suffered the loss
of
of several friends uh not the least of
which was
perhaps your best friend Alex Lowe right
who you lost in an avalanche in which
you were you know because you took a
different attack were able to survive
but you still you were in an avalanche
yes yeah and what year was that that was
99 right October 5th
and uh in the wake of that
um you ultimately ended up marrying his
his uh his bride and and taking in his
three sons and you guys have been
married now for 12 years 14 years yeah
yeah and so that's a very unique and
interesting experience that the film
explores in some respects
um but what was that like sort of
stepping into you know that family and
being responsible for raising those boys
it was a gift it was a it's been a
wonderful Journey
um and uh and it is sort of
shisha pongma is the one eight thousand
meter peak that's entirely in Tibet and
by Tibetan culture when there is a
um a fatality it's the brother that then
steps in and takes care of that the
Brothers family and so when we were
there the
the guys that were helping us out and
they were like oh my gosh and
even as we walked out of the mountains
and my shoulder was in a sling and I had
been banged up and cracked ribs and they
were like
we've got to take care of them and the
conversations you have a lot of these
people there they're not
they're not
the volume that you and I have had in
our own
native tongue or mother tongue back and
forth and big ideas and things like this
there's always sort of simple idea so
that might have been the foundation to
it and then coming back and being with
Jenny knowing
um max Sam and Isaac since Max was two
and then being there for Sam and Isaac's
birth and and being with them and um
that love is a you put love in the
equation it's a great healing thing and
Max's
with with us here and Jenny's with us
here and and when we're here in Southern
California and just working on a film
together and kind of um it's been a
great journey to have a family in that
sense and um
to uh
yeah it's a unique story I guess yeah
and I think I think what's also
you know an interesting kind of thing to
mine is how that impacted your
perception of climbing your risk
analysis
um
and
you know how you made choices about
future Expeditions because
at your core you are a climber this is
who you are this is what you do and and
you could
you know couldn't avoid climbing as much
as you could avoid having to go to the
bathroom like if this is this is you
know who you are it's in your DNA right
so how do you so it's this journey of
reconciling that with
you know the fact that that you're now
responsible for these boys who already
lost their father and and this woman who
already lost her husband
does that change how you
decide to tackle a climb
certain climes that have a higher level
of objective risk and that's walking
under something with a potential to
avalanche on your ice block breaking off
and that would be
um
what that was what killed Alex and David
and and shisha pangwa and so trying to
avoid those type of climbs but that
being said having
made 10 trips to the ice fall that
people can say well that's a load of
malarkey yeah I mean you still went
through everything so yeah so like oh
all right so what is acceptable risk I
mean your definition is is fluid and
distinct from the average human being
right like this is that's a moving
Target yeah and I've spent a lifetime
understanding the mountains and what
they
dynamics of snow and ice and that's
really the challenge in Himalayan Peaks
is that you have that level of um all
the ice that's hanging up there and how
do you how do you get around that but um
there's a
yeah
um
and if I were to go to if I were to go
into
a surgery theater and perform a surgery
I would botch it and I would kill that
person that's an unacceptable risk
analysis yeah and so that there's you
just it's whatever you do whatever you
know best and a good firefighter is
going to know all every time they step
into an incident they're going to learn
more about that building right and
that's what we're built upon and in your
experience in terms of
um where you are with
your podcasting podcasting
well but we all built on experience and
so there was um there's a
but I
this might sound
crazy but I I think that
yeah what I do I know when it's going to
be risky I on the right I'll go to Nepal
again and I'll do another trip and I'll
climb these climbs but I'm I'm there at
that moment and then I have to make
decisions and assess the situation and
the Locale and whether is it good to go
up and and things like that and make
sound decisions the best I can whether
or not and then also knowing that you
can always turn around and come back and
it's not climbing ultimately isn't worth
dying for and you want to come back and
and share that but that moment of making
that decision to turn around that like
critical
decision Point moment uh I would imagine
is informed by
deep intuition which is informed by a
lifetime of experience
which is
contributed to by your sense of hyper
vigilance right all of these things come
into play to help you make that decision
so I would imagine when an instinct
creeps up in you like we gotta go down
or we keep going that's not coming out
of nowhere that's coming out of a
lifetime of doing this yeah and so it's
a much more reliable Intuition or
Instinct than
the investment bankers yeah and you
might they might be able to make sound
decisions based on their experience with
it so
um
yeah it goes um
it's a
yeah it's I mean I could be a race car
driver that's dangerous stuff or
or I could have played football for a
bunch I mean there we know there's risk
associated with that and there's some
meet people that don't take care of
their bodies and they're
and where is that and so right
um yeah I mean you know people watch
what Alex Honnold does and it's
absolutely mind-boggling that somebody
could be so composed in you know in the
process of you know climbing up you know
those faces that he climbs without any
ropes without any safety net uh but he
will tell you
that he's done a risk analysis and that
there that he's completely comfortable
in in what he's tackling and to the
average person that it doesn't compute
at all right so that's what I mean about
like a sort of moving Target a risk
analysis based on experience
um
but when you look at
like on the subject of death you know
we're kind of still in the wake of of
Dean Potter's passing and and we're in
this kind of phase of of that version of
climbing which is very different kind of
climbing than you do where the envelope
is getting pushed and pushed and pushed
and it seems like to me as a layperson
that it's accelerating at a quite rapid
rate with the wingsuit jumps and the
slack lining and all this sort of thing
um to the extent that even you know
Cliff pulled out of sponsoring some of
these athletes because they're freaked
out at the risk level
um
you know what is your perception of that
as somebody who knows more about these
things than almost anyone else yeah and
I'm happy that people go out and they
push the limit and they they accept risk
and it's
um yeah people are going to say oh
they're absolutely crazy and you know
these proximity wingsuit jumpers the
fellows at thread needles and all these
things and they know what they're doing
and they know what the risk and the
consequences of those
of what's going on there and
that um
there's I'm
I think it's a healthy thing people need
to go out there and need to push the
envelope and it's whenever this happens
everyone's like oh Dean and this and
that and you know there's this huge
burden this cost to society and it's
like well
yeah it
having to do a body recovery in Yosemite
is less expensive than someone going
into
critical care or chronic care as an old
person or something like that I'm using
that as a very numbers-based type thing
so yeah Dean is a great guy
respect and yeah it's tragic and it's
sad especially for his family that that
were there that were so close to to him
and to be affected by it but um
to say that we should any of these
Pursuits where you're we're body injury
is is is a chance is should not be good
is a little bit crazy and so we're we
single out base jumpers and and climbers
soloists and all these Himalayan
climbers because it's super risky but
yet on the other side of it it's like
well
yeah we love football and in football
you're probably 89 chance that you're
going to have concussive cerebral
injuries and when you're my age then or
we're about the same age you're going to
be there's challenges that you're going
to have because you played football that
whole time and so
does Bud Light pull out of sponsoring
NFL because they know it was injurious
to people and it's a bad thing and yet
you know everyone's like we have an
energy bar that says oh we can't do this
on there so there's some
they're sort of
because it's we do this on our own
volition and there is a high
mortality rate and that it's
um
that you you it's a very
very brutal death flying into the
mountain there's nothing well yeah
they're spectacular yeah you know in car
range and now more and more they're
being filmed because everybody's got a
GoPro and that's a whole other you know
conversation about
um the sharing of these exploits and how
they might feel and inform you know some
people taking an unacceptable level of
risk you know to get the clip or
whatever but at the same time this is
the burden of the Explorer and the
Pioneer it's sort of like they've
accepted that mantle and that's that
goes with the territory and culturally
you know it's this not love hate but
like this weird relationship where we
want to see them do it but then this
weird shot and Freud when something bad
happens and then we have to have a you
know a cultural regrouping where we say
we can't do this anymore yeah you know
what I mean like we love our heroes but
we like to then attack them or criticize
them as well
so but it's fascinating to watch how
climbing is progressing in that regard
like I saw Valley Uprising and that was
quite amazing to see kind of the history
in Yosemite and how how it's evolved by
these guys you know sort of learning
from each other and
you know each person taking it to the
next level and but it does seem like
it's accelerating quite quickly right
now yeah they're being what's next yeah
well I look at mountain biking it was
like it was sort of like a member of the
coaster bikes with the reverse brake
yeah and you'd like do a skid turn
around the trees and that was like
mountain biking and that right the
riding these spines and right well Danny
mccaskill what he does in those movies
it's unbelievable so it's um and I'm
happy for it this is
let's go I mean it's um we've got 350
million people in the United States and
and we are here because we're 320 or
whatever million we have seven and a
half billion on this planet and
you can as long as you're not harming
other people and and malicious and and
mean and things like that go out and
have fun and so it um yeah it's a it's a
intense conversation and I'm at
the I have a very
firm views on it because I get I have a
Target on my back because of that
because I'm they're like well
you know here you are you lost your best
friend climbing and then you marry his
widow and you raise his kids to be
climbers and the same thing and just
that's not a good thing and so some
people think it's their prerogative to
come in and tell other people how to
live right so how do you respond to that
I'm a
it's uh well there's one way you can say
it you know opinions are like
toothbrushes everyone has their own
toothbrush you don't necessarily want to
share them but there's
um
air
I I generally don't I mean
I don't don't engage I don't engage
because it just doesn't it doesn't uh
the people that mean a lot to me they
understand and people that are are
friends and they know where we're at and
that have a um
a meaningful life they understand that
and there's some
a meaningful Life by my standards people
that have the same value set and so and
you understand why we go out and do
these things and what what's important
in life and perhaps many of the
listeners out there do too so yeah and I
think that's one of the things that meru
addresses you know like Mallory isn't
isn't Mallory the one who's responsible
for the quote when asked like why do you
climb and why do you tackle these
mountains and he said because it's there
yeah so we all know that quote we didn't
necessarily know that it was Mallory you
said it but meru kind of updates that
response in some regard yeah and I won't
spoil it you should go out and see the
movie but it's a much more nuanced
um thing and that you know and I've been
thinking a lot about
balance lately subject of balance and
and moderation you know and as somebody
who's done Ultra endurance events and
and you know and I know what that's like
and it's kind of a different version of
what you do what you do it has some kind
of overlap and you know last weekend I
went out to Utah to help the iron Cowboy
finishes 50th Ironman in 50 states in 50
days and you know what he's accomplished
is just extraordinary you know it really
it defies
I think it's one of the greatest
achievements in human endurance and it
was really touching and beautiful to be
there to to witness it and
and to see the response of people like
he had like over a thousand people there
cheering him on in his home state of
Utah and it was the amount of love that
was surrounding him it was really cool
and yet we're in this culture where this
idea of balance is reinforced like live
a balanced life and everything in
moderation and all this sort of thing
and and I've always said like I struggle
with balance like I've isolate between
extremes and I'm just prone to that I'm
attracted to that I'm magnetized to that
and what does that mean is that a good
thing is that a bad thing should I
refrain from judging that but when you
look at sort of
the great achievements of mankind these
were achieved by people who were
arguably out of balance by our sort of
cultural Paradigm you know definition of
of what that is it's sort of like
we're told to be in balance yet we
celebrate people that are out of balance
but then we tell them you're out of
balance
you know what I mean like does that make
sense to you like what how do you how do
you kind of you know
approach balance and you know I think I
think
in the macro sense you're living a very
Balanced Life you're a great dad to
these three boys you're you know you
you're a loving husband you've been
married 14 years you go off and do these
extreme things but if someone's you know
like when you're
on the mountain maybe your life is
temporarily out of balance but in the
macro like I think you're living a
balanced life where your priorities are
in check thank you you know what I mean
like
so I'm sure you get this question all
the time or you know that criticism of
living out of balance I mean maybe
that's just a different variation on the
question I just asked you but yeah
well I hope that that it is in balance
and that um being in the mountains and
doing these Expeditions bring some
degree of balance back to it so that
and it's the that Adventure out there
and yes we do you look at Lewis and
Clark that marched across North America
and they were
um you know they were seen as crazy and
and they weren't the same thing with
Shackleton at his time in this time it
wasn't
it wasn't when he came back not having
made it across Antarctica and in 1917
and that was
it became a hero later in life so we're
um yes it's one of those things public
Figures it's a different well I also
think that
because being a climber is who you are
and climbing is what you do that when
you're climbing you are in your bliss so
you are balanced in that regard like you
are grounded and present and you are you
are the best version of yourself when
you are engaged in doing that yeah
because that's what you love to do and
if people can find that in whatever they
do and whether it's becoming
the best Barista that makes the most
perfect
flowers on the phone or the best chess
player or artist or and when people have
a sense of purpose and a drive and what
they want to do that is probably the
most important thing and a lot of people
that I communicate with that are in HR
and employing people that's one of the
things they look for is this is this
person have something they're passionate
about and they want to Excel and they
want to do good at and then ask about
that and those are traits that then
encourage people to do good and I'm
fortunate to have found that climbing
was my calling and being able to follow
it and especially thankful to Society
for allowing me to pursue it to the
degree that I have but also giving back
right like so let's talk about
mentorship a little bit I mean you had
great mentors and and now you're at a
point in your career where mentoring the
younger generation has become an
important thing to you and that's
reflected in the in the movie as well uh
with Jimmy and Renard and it's you know
I'm interested in exploring kind of what
that means to you and and how you carry
that man
well we um we're at the sum total of
everyone that came before us so if we
look at this Collective ball of
knowledge and each generation passes it
on and is able to add to it and then
move it on to the next one and so if you
can
get close to that ball of energy or hold
the ball or touch it and then you're
there to to bring it to the hands of the
Next Generation you're I mean that's
sort of what mentorship is about and you
look at where we are as humans today
with everything from technology and
science and
the Arts and philosophy it's all related
to humans
moving that
ball of knowledge forward and then
sharing it with the next with the
previous generation and climbing is very
particular in that way because
it's so it's a mechanical type thing
because you have to set up the ropes you
have the carabiners there's belay
techniques there's you have to setting
things up and so I had someone that
literally showed me the ropes and so
there's that that learning of how to do
it and yes you can learn to climb as a
kid without any prior education you see
kids climbing up trees and on Boulders
and it's just innate in them they get
out and they want to go to the top of
that little hump there they want to
climb that tree and Mom's like ah get
down dad's like be safe and so we're
kind of untraining them from that and
then right you want to see a mountain
you're like I want to go climb there and
then you have to learn from those those
uh that rope and everything on that and
there's um
in terms of like mentorship there's
nothing I can teach Alex and old I mean
the guy's way better climber than it
ever was or ever will be and so there's
not like from a climbing standpoint but
but he doesn't have experience in the
kind of climbing that you do yeah or
life experience and things like that and
then encouraging them and and that was
for me what my great when mugs who was
my mentor said yeah you can do this and
then to to say that you can do it and to
give them that responsibility rather
than sort of hanging on to it and and
and saying being possessive of it but to
say okay
your it's your turn now and you move on
and I think that's uh for an athlete
that's our age to
rather than trying to say oh I'm gonna
try to be there with those guys and try
to compete with them and all this and
that you should be like wow
um age gracefully and be supportive of
the people and and realize that
when you pursue it at
whatever level you're doing that the
essence of doing it that that Joy of
doing it is the same as when you were
doing it at the very highest level so
there's
um like the old time climbers
that were climbing the gunks into their
80s and so they had pioneered the sport
but they were still going out there and
climbing at this a very
a level that gave them a ton of fun
right interesting yeah and there's the
beautiful moment in the movie where
uh you're about to finally Summit meru
and it's all lined up for you to be the
first one up and and you sort of pass
the mantle on to Jimmy and that's sort
of a very palpable like tactile way of
saying you know I'm the mentor and
you're the Next Generation it's a
beautiful moment it was uh I heard that
it wasn't originally in the movie either
right like that's such a huge character
you know moment in the movie yeah chai
discovered it so she's like ah this is
it yeah it was um it was sort of like uh
the um but at that point we had we were
so close in 2008 and then so we
basically did the Second Ascent all the
way up except for those last two pitches
yeah right one of them was really time
consuming and difficult that was the one
that we turned back on that would have
forced us in overnight and it would have
just been
um we did the right thing we got back
and no one was injured and Looking Back
Now on the story of meru that it yeah
from 2003 to 2011 the time that took me
eight years to climb it
was that was fitting that it was there
but when we got to that being that close
it was like okay
Jimmy it's your lead and right we're
gonna get to the top but it's always um
when I'm with my climbing Partners I'm
always like
you go first to the
and
I remember a great guy Jay Smith that I
climbed with and we'd always be like oh
you first known you get to the summit we
just like almost get into like no no no
no no no after you to be the first
person to to stand on this the summit
because you were kind of a team and it's
one of those the level of trust and the
bond that you have with those guys when
your life is literally in their hands is
got to be like nothing else yeah and as
a kid I love running and I love
going out and doing track and I always
hear about these races where there'd be
two guys and they would be like
struggling doing the marathon and then
they would come through the
the Finish Line hand in hand and when it
is a team that would be just like wow
that's pretty cool I mean those things
well that goes back to your earliest
sort of perception of sport and being
kind of you know anti
the competitive aspect of it the the
Victor versus the also Iran yeah and it
was I mean there's probably other things
in it but it was um
um you know having a
a unique name and kind of and just
you know some playing football on a
military base in Frankfurt Germany as a
kid and it was just like whoa I mean it
was it was uh
there was sort of this
this
um
I didn't respond it just was difficult I
mean the right The Bullying that went on
there as a kid I was like oh so I'm
gonna do the opposite whenever I see
someone that can I can lend a hand or
help out to or um so I mean even it I
think it changed my life because I
wasn't the one that was I was I had to
be
and
maybe it changed who I am but it was I
sort of was like oh this isn't
at the end of the day I didn't feel like
a good person I didn't feel like that
they were my it was my team but I just
it was just sort of like
wasn't you I didn't wasn't you so well I
realized that we didn't even set the
stage about what mehru is and and sort
of the uh
the Mystique around this particular
Mountain the sharks fin uh in particular
and how that had kind of defied climbers
for 30 years of attempts right no one
had been able to Summit this and you'd
made a couple attempts and the movie is
really a Chronicle of you know trying to
finally be the first guys up there yeah
foreign
yeah there was this one there's there's
three Peaks on meru in the central has
this shark fin that looks like a
um almost like a like a shark spin or a
like the flame of a candle that kind of
comes up out of a
base of this Glacier and there's really
aesthetic looking and teams had tried it
but it was
many climbs you'll have the most
difficult stuff at the at the lower part
and then intermediate stuff in the
middle and the easy stuff on the top the
middle stuff was still middle stuff on
this climb but the easy stuff was at the
bottom and the most typical stuff was
the top so that slow going big wall
climbing like you have on Yosemite and
El Capitan that required
we had to get that equipment up to the
base of that and that brought the
necessity of more equipment and more
time going into it
one of the themes that kind of comes
across is
your approach to climbing uh in terms of
uh perceiving the long game right like
not just
not rushing things being able to have a
responsible level of patience and you
know knowing when to back down and that
goes back into acceptable risk but but
always having the long game in mind
right can you elaborate on that a little
bit
there
well I guess the base of it the
Mountain's always there another day so
if you don't make it up that day you can
try it again but um that we're always
climbing at the being fortunate with the
weather that there's a um a break in the
weather and that we're we're not
conquering it necessarily but rather
we're finding an opportunity to climb it
that gives us the uh sort of the a break
in that right so that's sort of the um
the the basis of that the um
but also
that um
they're just to be always a little bit
more patient so
um it's
you'll get there eventually
so which is tough because if you're too
patient in driving here in La you'll
never get there you know I'm like if you
really want to get an ahead of me go
ahead right people just drive fast and
like
[Music]
yeah we will slow down and let the
pedestrians Cross or something like that
but it um you know they're
the long game we're always
um live to see another day
I'm interested in exploring uh something
you I'm sure you get asked about all the
time so my apologies but it has to do
with you know your relationship with
fear right
um which I think is probably unique uh
and it's interesting because we kind of
live in a fear-based culture right if
you watch the news everything is
premised upon like making us very afraid
right like don't go outside or terrorist
attacks or or what have you
um and the kind of fear that you deal
with is is very different
um
is it about conquering fear is it
accepting fear is it that you're not
afraid like how does that work for you
fear and it's very Basic Instinct is our
self-preservation Instinct and so that's
what has driven humans to become where
we are so we can see what fear is and
then change it and
and and do and make decisions based upon
it and the fear that I encounter is on
by my own volition so I'm going to go up
on this big wall and it's a Scary Place
humans aren't meant to be with that
amount of exposure and in those type of
temperatures and things like that so I
can overcome that fear with experience
and by having the right equipment and
things like that and then that knowledge
that I've been in a similar situation in
the past and that I can then do it but
um
I tend to
um
I'm very accepting of humans so I'm not
like oh I'm in a this is a rough part of
town I should be afraid I'll be like
okay I'm here and I have good intent I'm
not I'm not trying to do anything and
I've never had any problems with that
and maybe I'm naive or something like
that and but I think a lot of fears is
conditioned upon what Society
tells us and so we might be like
we make snap judges we're looking at a
certain person and saying well that
person is going to be bad there's going
to be problems with it and they're going
to to see things in a different way and
to really not make judgments about
people particularly or locations or
places that you are will make you less
fearful and
um
there's a yeah what do I fear in life
yeah
driving because it's so fast and you see
car accidents and you're like oh my God
driving keeps coming up as a theme here
it's definitely something that triggers
you well I spent three hours driving
yesterday and it was
I mean yeah you drive from Bozeman to
Missoula and you put it on cruise
control and you can uh download a couple
podcasts and
you're just
looking out there and and so but yeah
when you're on the 405 in rush hour like
I was last night it was a scary
experience I was like white knuckling
that Conrad anchor is terrified of the
405 but nehru is not an issue yeah well
meru I knew what I was getting into and
the cold is an adversary that I can
understand and I can I can work with it
but
um so the semi on the 405 and Lane
Changers and the motorcyclists that are
splitting Lanes I mean those guys scare
me because what if I wasn't paying it
100 attention at that time and I clipped
them and they had a wipe out and I don't
want to have that on my shoulders I mean
it's just like all these things are
landing on me
deal with them at one moment so how do
these high-stakes Adventures that you've
been on kind of inform how you navigate
your daily life you know I think you
know somebody might say well you're
you're so used to this extreme level of
excitement
that the rest of your life might be
boring but I have a feeling that that's
not the case no it it's things if you on
most these Expeditions the ones that
I've done with Jimmy like walking across
to bed and you end up running out of
food so it's like okay and you end up
dehydrating yourself and all those
things so when you come back you're like
wow
this is tea this is really cool and I
went to the coffee shop and the person
made me a cup of coffee and it cost me
two dollars I mean it's like really
amazing yeah and I'm like happy and
thankful for that person and they're
like it's like a good human interaction
so that and you're able to hold on to
that not having so not having all these
Creature Comforts I mean so many people
are like they're just like so like what
my coffee is five degrees off and I'm in
a rush and all right does it take you
that long and just a little bit of
patience and courtesy with those things
and especially for the people that are
working there and that um I think that
that influences so sort of that being on
these long Expeditions makes you
appreciate the simple things in life
like
a soft bed and a well-prepared meal and
and conversations and your cell phone
working things like that and I mean
nowadays it's sort of like we're so
programmed that my gosh I don't have
five bars on my 3G that's a disaster or
I spilled coffee on you only have 3G oh
now it's 14 yeah
but yeah I guess I'm really out of it
now so okay I didn't get the models just
come on old man yeah I mean my phone has
a clip-in loop on it I know I know
that's right what I do with them you
clip that onto your belt like how does
that work oh yeah until you can hang it
there I'm gonna take a picture of that
yeah how you um you can also put it on
your wrist you can girth hitch it you
can hang it in your tent so you could
right gotcha listen to a ritual podcast
and which is you know download a bunch
of these things up on the portal Edge
these have changed Expedition climbing I
mean it's sort of like
I mean back in the day we would have
walkmans and we'd have cassettes and I
remember there's always one side of the
cassette that was better than the other
so you'd sit there and you'd get a
number two pencil and you'd rewind the
whole thing so you could listen to that
tape again and then the batteries would
get low and it wouldn't just shut off
and go right right now you can watch
movies and TV shows movies TV shows
listen all your music you can you can
update your address book I mean it's I
mean this technology the way technology
has advanced in the last 10 or 15 years
has got me completely excited for what
it's going to be doing in the next 10 to
15 years well that gets into kind of you
know you're also an entrepreneur it
seems like you've got you know 10
businesses going and all kinds of other
stuff uh you know off the mountain as
well right what's going on what's the
what's the latest
thing that you're working on right now
we um yeah if you have ideas follow your
ideas and so I'm kind of a idea person I
get people excited about them and then I
want to get them rolling on that idea
and we build them together but um and
working with um meeting various people
from various disciplines and so uh Bruce
Johnson who's a research clinician from
the Mayo Clinic in Rochester Minnesota
he and I were in Everest together in in
2012 and then working with another Alex
Phillip out of Missoula Montana who's a
data and another fellow Stephen Marshall
who's out of London San Francisco area
and so coming together with these
different ideas that we can then pulling
into different areas and that what we're
working on now is this our working
title on this is working group it's is
medalist which is medical data and
lifestyle and so if we have three each
of these three medalists yeah so there's
um so it's just an acronym right I
gotcha so pulled them all together so we
have
we're looking at the health of the
people in the United States so this what
we're talking about now is Health where
people are how they're staying healthy
and and the cost to it so
um
Alex is a data guy and so he works with
big data so he's from a GIS background
and so they've done mapping and things
like that and then now that we can keep
adding layers and layers of data so you
can add in stuff from the Census you can
add in stuff data from the Center for
Disease Control and prevention and you
can look at all these different areas
and then kind of figure out the health
of individuals and it comes down to
where you live down to really so if you
are again another sort of blue zones
analogy it is and so working with that
and trying to tie in with what Dan
boitner has been working on with that so
it's again extrapolating on that so
they're able to look at say if you are
um in an area that is downwind of an oil
refinery your chance you're going to be
that much more likely to have melanoma
if you live in
East L.A and this is your demographic
and you live in a food desert your risk
of type 2 diabetes is going to be that
much greater if and so breaking it down
into each of these individual areas and
you can look at it county by county in
in the United States of where people are
healthy and what they're not doing and
so taking that information and then
they're sort of a that's the data part
of it so we can look at macro data which
is big amounts of data that looks at
every level of where people are where
they're healthy what they're doing in
society and then you have the Micro Data
which is the data that you would get off
say of a a fitness watch or your own
medical test that tells you on a
day-to-day basis how healthy you are and
that's improving all the time because
you can look on your right you can track
what you're eating on your phone and be
more aware of that and the more aware of
it that you are so trying to combine Big
Data Micro Data macro and Micro Data on
that so that's the data compartment and
then there's the medical component of
the and that is the hospitals which are
the providers there's the insurance
companies which are the payers and then
there's Pharma which is the other part
of that and then the third component of
it is lifestyle and that's where guys
like you and I fit in because we're out
there as proponents for a healthy
lifestyle what are we going to do to get
healthier and be healthier and so
having read Dan's book having met Dan at
a conference and interacted with some
great guy kind of like I'm fascinated by
that so he's taking data he's not just
saying oh I heard about guys families
that live in Georgia were in the
caucuses that eat yogurt that lived to
be 120 he's actually gone down and mined
the data and knows exactly where they
are and then trying to pull that out and
some of your podcasts are about those
those you know linking data the guy that
says okay there's more phds in
Switzerland they eat more chocolate so
if you eat chocolate you're gonna be
smarter I mean it's like let's let's get
really focused on this and looking at it
so then working with our group that we
have there and we sort of meet in a way
that we're just brainstorming we're not
trying to sell anything to anyone like
that but how can we bend the curb on the
health of of people and so the lifestyle
part of it is where we get out and we
exercise we encourage people to to live
a healthy life to eat healthier to be
more mindful of what they're doing to
their bodies and then the other part of
the lifestyle is that it it does come
into
our society which is is governed by
government and and that is run by
politics so you have an example in New
York City where they say you the 72
ounce drinks there's something we have
to Sue that and some people have to
change that there's too much sugar in
there and so other people are saying
you're taking away our the right to be
in that point so
bringing all of those groups together
and then brainstorming on ways that we
can help create a healthier Society
that's kind of our right our that's a
big lofty goal it's a big lofty but it's
a worthy one yeah and if someone's going
on and we have fun with it and um it's
really it's neat to see
um to to engage all these different
areas and so right they're um yeah it's
interesting I mean it's really similar
to what Dan's doing with his blue zones
projects and how he goes into these
cities you know because he'll tell you
and he probably said to you like the the
best way to help people is to change
their environment so when you look at
for example the example you used a you
know in East LA neighborhood that's a
food desert well we now realize that the
the incidence of type 2 diabetes there
is because it's a food desert so how do
we change that like you know we're not
going to get all these people to move
and you know you they can all go see
meru and be inspired but is that going
to translate into them changing their
Habits Like that's a harder thing you
know what I mean but if you can surround
them with healthier options that are at
an arm's length away or you know build
bike paths or you know I don't know you
know certain kinds of kinds of um
you know uh things that are in the
environment that kind of foster a
healthier lifestyle is the way that
you're gonna ultimately get these
communities to improve and the harsh
reality is that people respond to
economic incentive and so the insurance
companies are seeing this they're saying
where's a type 2 diabetic is going to
cost us
two hundred thousand dollars or
something like that especially if it's I
mean it can be really and that's just
one of the the five
um top killers that are that that are
lifestyle related so they have an
incentive to say let's see if we can
incentivize people to become healthier
rather than paying for another three
Wings in a big hospital like right for
the employers too because they're the
ones who have to pay these insurance
premiums you know for their Workforce
those are what Wellness programs yeah
and as companies become more Progressive
and they understand their their Wellness
programs and so it's um and it's I'm I'm
excited because I'm a mountain climber
but I get to hang out with these really
bright people in in medicine and and
data and kind of get ideas going there
I'm sure they're very excited to hang
out with you too that's probably you're
probably the coolest guy that they get
to hang out with I brought to basketball
all right so a couple questions I want
to ask you before we before we wrap it
up the first one is
you know in raising these three boys you
know what are the what are the values
that are most important to you that you
instill in them as they mature into men
the
um I guess there's a a sense of decency
and compassion for other humans is is
the the end goal that we want to have
with raising the children Jenny and I so
to be
kind and generous to other people and so
that's a good
um
foundation for that and as a parent to
get there there's
um there's expectations and boundaries
So and I've set them on myself and so
what do you
um what are those expectations and
boundaries and everyone has a different
set of them and with our boys the our
expectations is that
you'll play an instrument in high school
you'll learn a second language in high
school and you'll Graduate University
and so they get those three things done
I think they'll have those
and we're fortunate to be able to do
that not everyone has that ability I
realize that and I don't want to sound
like I'm
like sorry I want to sound I don't want
to sound pompous I want to say I got
grounded I got you those are the values
and that's what's important to us the
instrument thing though because you were
a trumpet player and your dad was a
trumpet player right yeah some music
yeah there's a sense of tenacity that
you and repetition practice and then
language and music they build neural
Pathways that we Now understand that are
beneficial so and
maybe computer games are doing the same
things we they're still out there but
the computer games are kind of more of a
treat they're kind of like a soft serve
ice cream cone they're not really like
you've got to go learn a second language
so
so have any of your boys discovered like
that passion that's gonna fuel their
life yet do they know what they want to
do and be yeah
um max is the oldest and he's uh a
photographer and a videographer and he's
really enjoying that um in the outdoor
space and so not as an athlete as Alex
and I am um but more in sort of the
sharing the story and doing things and
loves that Sam is going into a senior
year as a
film student at Montana State so he
loves stop animation and making movies
and and those kind of things and Isaac
is a freshman at Western Washington and
Bellingham with a keen interest in the
Natural Sciences and ecology so they're
um and it's that's cool so they all have
a pretty good idea of yeah they're what
they're interested they want to do
something that's that's really that's
good and and you know if they wanted to
well good job lounge around and eat
potato chips I would I would find joy in
that I wouldn't want to be too harsh on
them but
yeah I'm I'm a task master are you are
you are you a little bit of a hard ass
or no I think so are you I mean yeah my
fellow teammates make a joke about it
and I'm on Expedition and I'm that way
with myself and it um and it's uh
there's um you know as when
those formative years those the the
boundaries and expectations I think are
two key parts to Parenting that that um
and that you can understand that and so
there's certain
um certain things so it doesn't come as
a surprise and you want to get your
children set to when they eventually
become the go out in society that it is
you have to earn your keep it's hard
work out there not everyone's going to
be friendly but if you're friendlier
you'll you'll have better luck and you
might be happier at it so
if you could go back in time and give a
20 year old Conrad anchor a little piece
of advice
based upon what you've learned what
would that be I would be
probably do more stretching and more
yoga that's it well there's probably
other bigger philosophically
philosophically
um we could all stretch a little more
yeah I mean so yeah yoga is great and
it's just
but um
in the breathing aspect of it probably
oh it
probably in your 20s he was a young
person you're kind of self-absorbed I
mean the world's about you you don't
realize that your impact with other
people and things like that so and that
comes with um
that that knowledge that wisdom comes
with experience and age and some people
are born with it and some people have it
through circumstance and experiences
that have changed them
if you got a tap on your shoulder
uh
by the next president said Conrad I'd
like you to be Secretary of the Interior
you know as somebody who's more in touch
with our natural resources and our
natural environment
um
you know if you were given that kind of
responsibility over uh managing our
resources
what do you think what do you think
needs
us to what do you where do you think our
attention should be focused well patch
off first to Sally Jewell she's doing a
great job as Secretary of the Interior
and she comes from a recreation
background and it's
she manages her department and team
manages more land in the United States
and then anyone along those lines but
the challenge is when in the interior is
that you have national forests and you
have BLM land you have public land it
has resources on them and how do we
look at those various
um
the the assets that are held within
those lands whether it's Timber coal or
natural gas those are the sort of the
three
Peak ones that were there and yes we
need to have energy to run our society
and these microphones are powered by it
and where we can't escape that and the
first step to understanding
energy consumption this is knowing that
we consume it at what level and trying
to to be mindful of that but um some of
the other
um ways that we would uh
see the um
the the the the price that we pay for
carbon fuel here assistance the United
States is below the market value in the
rest of the world so I go to Nepal and
it's a poor landlocked country they have
no uh coal or natural gas they have some
Hydro um and how do they what is the
price of gasoline for their vehicles
it's about four times what we pay here
so that influences their decisions and
how they they do that um and and so
again it comes back to what we were
mentioning about the market economy
affecting change within people we look
at Hawaii where electricity is something
far more expensive than it is here
on the mainland United States that
because all the the carbon that's used
to generate the electricity has to be
reported so all of a sudden solar is
very cost effective so as the price of
conventional electricity rises in the
price of alternative energy wind solar
and hydro drops Hydro is more fixed than
those other two because the technology
is continually improving then it becomes
more of a it's a different change and so
if I had that job and I wouldn't want it
yeah it can't be it can't be an easy job
yeah you have a lot of people that
you're trying to keep happy and it's um
it's a lot of respect for anyone that
takes on that works in the government
and always I'm not I always thank people
that work in the government rather than
being antagonistic and angry at them but
the
finding that that point where we can
address
that energy consumption is sort of the
the key thing that that we need to get
our as a cult as a country in the United
States and that's when we're something
like seven percent of the world's
population yet we consume about 30
percent of the world's resources
although China emits more CO2 than we do
we are per capita far more as each
individual we use more energy and so
there's that um this point now where
where maybe peak oil isn't the debate
that we're going to have as much because
we we become more efficient in terms of
ways that we can get carbon out of the
ground by being more resourceful and
drilling deeper and and cracking the
rock and steaming it out of there all
these different techniques we're
becoming more efficient at it but it
instead of peak oil becoming that the
point that we have to be concerned about
it might be Peak carbon so what do we do
is we go above 400 parts per million and
how is that ocean acidification
atmospheric CO2 and glacial recession
those are the three
undeniable ways that we can measure our
anthropogenic impact on climate
have you seen cowspiracy yet
cowspiracy it's a documentary oh I'm
familiar I haven't seen it but it's
about the methane yeah yeah actually I
think I got a DVD in my car I'll give it
to you but it basically is looking it's
looking at that very issue through the
prism of the impact of animal
agriculture on the environment and and
and and and really evaluating you know
the extent to which that's kind of the
elephant in the room that no one's
talking about but it really is having a
devastating impact on on everything from
you know desertification rainforest
destruction ocean pollution you know you
name it carbon emissions through the
roof all those sorts of things but I
think you'd be interested in checking it
out yeah yeah that's uh yeah and thanks
to you for inspiring a healthier
lifestyle so Wow since I've gotten to
know you I mean I've changed my uh you
know it's a cool thing oh cool man
that's good to hear thank you but uh I
mean you're the you're you know you're
quite the inspirational figure and and
um
I hope that you uh continue doing what
you do I think you inspire a lot of
people and your message is very powerful
and so I think the way to close it down
is just to
um maybe have you share a few words for
somebody who's out there who
perhaps is yearning for a little bit
more Adventure or outdoors in their life
but they're stuck you know they're
sitting in their cubicle they're at work
right now listening to this wishing they
were Outdoors but you know that person
who just has trouble taking that first
step yeah well wherever you are probably
in North America where you're listening
to this or if you're in Europe or pretty
much anywhere there is some degree of
Nature close by you can always find a
place that has trees and plants and
things that are that the random beauty
of Nature and so we're so you're in a
cubicle you're in this human right angle
construct there's plastic there's steel
there's concrete and it's even like the
tablecloth here has right angles and
it's everything is built into that and
when you go outdoors and you go for a
run on the trail even the trail and the
dirt on it is is chaos it's random and
then there's the trees and all that and
that's knowing that that Wilderness this
might not be Wilderness but that nature
is there
can rejuvenate your soul and make you
happy so
um
start out by going for a walk go for a
run check out the climbing gym these
that'll help you understand what
climbing is go visit a cliff
um but um don't fall off the cliff don't
fall off the cliff but challenge
yourself but yeah instead of um instead
of doing something that you've always
done do something that challenges
yourself and let that uh
that that fear of that grip of anxiety
in your stomach saying I can't do this
let that be your motivator
and as you say
be good be kind and be happy be happy
right yeah a little this might like
that's your Mantra yeah so I I like to
share it with people so because
um goodness leads to kindness and
kindness plus goodness equals happiness
so but it's nothing I created I mean
it's out there that's there's people
that are um
that are there so thank you Rich yeah
thank you so much man
this is a joy and a pleasure and an
honor it's really great to talk to you
uh you inspire me every day and I love
following your journey online as it
continues to unfold and I'm really
excited for everybody to see this movie
and learn more about not just climbing
but but your life and and kind of um
have that own dialogue with themselves
about challenging themselves so it's
going to be cool man
you're in for a good ride when this
movie comes out I think it's going to be
cool thank you so uh if you're digging
on on Conrad the best place to check
them out Conrad anchor.com and his
Instagram feed is epic it's at Conrad
underscore anchor right
anywhere else to check you out yeah um
those are yeah that's the main thing
right yeah there's Facebook and and
those things but um yeah they're um
Instagram's a great Community yeah
pictures and yeah your feed's amazing I
love it
so cool all right man well uh come back
and talk to me again we'll talk so you
do that yeah all right man thanks so
much peace
plants
[Music]